[Music]
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy it's my
favorite time of the day critic I don't
think the girls in the 90s wore this
many hair products I was like punky
Brewster's recycling bin and where are
my pants this baggy also why are all the
logos on the back it's all part of the
experience now sit down before it starts
before what starts you're just pressing
play on the DVD player you don't
understand this is the Disney Afternoon
this is something ritual to this yes
like we just got back from school tour
belongings on the ground for our mothers
to pick up surround ourselves in
high-fructose corn syrup and reward
ourselves we're dealing with the mental
scars of our tremendously flawed
education system wait aren't you talking
about Disney's one Saturday morning on
ABC look this means one Saturday morning
on ABC that was just a carbon copy
cartoon comparison compared to the
Disney Afternoon hey pepper Ann was good
maybe one recess was decent if you want
get technical and Kim Possible can
possible obviously but eyebrow family
was just on the prowl family nobody this
was the Pratt family long around and
there was also that other show Doug yeah
that was a pretty good cartoon series
you can't deny that must have had some
sort of impact on your life what you're
both missing is that the Disney
Afternoon had a timeless sense of magic
and Wonder that was the perfect welcome
home from a long day of school house
popularity or awkward social punishment
so if there's no other comparisons to
lesser forms of art we'll go ahead and
get started for the first time ever from
1990 to 1997 Disney took some of its hit
syndicated shows and ran them with all
new material in the two-hour block
called the Disney Afternoon sure there
were some reruns and specials featuring
the old classic Disney cartoons before
then but this was the first time Disney
put a slew of new programming
back-to-back in one glorious line up
most of the timeless some of it not so
much but we'll get to that when we get
to that let's look at Disney's first
installment gummi big
and yes the first thing you're thinking
pops into everybody else's head to why
and or how do you make a show based on a
fruit snack whose head and limbs you
disturbingly bite off well despite such
a distracting commercial tie in the show
surprisingly it wasn't that bad although
they had to deal with it's bright colors
fantasy focused environment and a theme
song sung by the most easily excitable
group ever just listen to how into it
these guys get it's impossible not to
get sucked in yourself
[Music]
magic and mystery are part of their
history along with the secret of
gummiberry juice
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll know affect the singer actually
died on that very last note he was that
into it
[Music]
the show sands around a boy named Kevin
he lives in a kingdom tried to be
conquered by a group of full girls led
by the egotistical Duke King Gragas
Castle will be nothing but a big pile of
grabba gets moving time is money
or it would be if I were paying you
truth be told I always thought the tube
through most of my childhood was just
Skeletor before he lost his flesh in
fact maybe this all takes place in the
same universe and Skeletor is just the
Dukes ghost
[Music]
Nicolle am I going to chase him Kevin
stumbles across the group of enchanted
cereal mascots and learns of their
secret weapon that can defeat the Duke a
liquid that gives them super-strength
and jumping abilities called gummiberry
juice you know don't you come up with a
better name for such a gigantic source
of power when the force lose a little
bit of its magic if it was called
something different you must use a yummy
Muffy puffy so it's a constant battle
between our lovable plush toys and the
evil monsters and sorcerers that plagued
the land show had an innocence to it
that made it silly but still pretty
enjoyable but maybe a lot of the show's
intrigue came from the fact that it
sounded like most of the bears ate your
favorite cartoon characters like
Garfield
he's more homesick than we are Tigger oh
no oh no not cubby that's just a story
Natasha
Rafi got me you have the manners of a
billy goat Tony Curtis
so let's you tell me who I like and who
I don't like and of course Nicolas Cage
alas since the lorry the teddy bears
have their picnic honestly the show
works so surprisingly well I'm kind of
wondering at Disney maybe should
consider doing other shows based on
bite-sized treats
it was only the first show in the lineup
next was the always popular DT why don't
you just say the title because I have
literally 24 years after its release
have just now gotten the theme song out
of my head and I don't want to risk
putting it back in my head by possibly
saying the title once more
you mean ducktales as many of you know
I've talked about this show several
times in the past on both my Raiders of
the story arc and of course my top 11
catchy as themes should we call a
village it's too late for him so I won't
waste too much time on this one
but we can talk a little bit about it
the show sire on Scrooge McDuck looking
after Huey Dewey and Louie as their
parents once again refused to take any
responsibility for them and all the
adventures and crazy characters they
encounter finding treasure it's sort of
like Indiana Jones meets duck EULA does
anyone remember that I don't care
despite the fact that the focus of the
story is continuing to reward the 1% the
show still kicks ass even years later
giving us all sorts of memorable
secondary characters like Launchpad then
which duck that inventor duck the chubby
woodchuck duck and Robo duck
hey I said the characters were memorable
not the names it's still smart it's
still creative and it's still incredibly
likeable it has just as much charm now
as it did back then but surely there
must be another Disney title that also
made a thumb bleeding ly good Capcom
games
now we're talking Chippendales Rescue
Rangers was the famous chipmunk duo
forming a team to help and save anyone
in danger think of them as an anti pinky
and the bird you know Chip and Dale of
course but on top of that there was
gadget zipper and Monterey Jack and one
of these characters were memorable and
extremely likeable it did subtly make me
realize the traditional team formula
that lingered over most kids shows for
example you have the inventor you have
the muscle you have the leader you have
the goof off and of course one that's
just so darn adorable but let's be fair
this is when that formula was just
starting to be put into effect and give
the show credit for putting two popular
characters on a team instead of just
keeping it to people whose real voices
sound like Babs bunny and the crazy taxi
guy fighting over the same woman I gotta
hand it to you gadget you were right
about Tom after all I always believed in
you most of the time was spent fighting
off evil schemes usually from the
diabolical fat cat hello my galvanized
feline friend and surprisingly he has no
political ties despite the fact that his
name is in fact fat cat well I guess he
does look at touch Y Christopher
Christie my million-dollar dinner gone
down the drain while we're on the
subject did you know that Chip and Dale
were actually modeled after Indiana
Jones and magnum p.i God wouldn't it
been a totally different show if it
matched their personalities too you
stood up to be counted with the enemy of
everything that the Grail stands for who
gives a damn what you think did you come
here just to abuse me the characters
allow for a lot of event of storylines
and ideas like Antron being the wrong
equivalent of MacGyver I mean good god
just look at half the things she makes
don't be silly chips idea
hey Tamara can you make a car out of a
skateboard and a hairdryer no all I can
do is a Chevy pickup truck sculpted out
of rubber and ice your dad's also to
craft a lot of characters lent their way
to learning some good lessons to like
always be yourself have confidence in
your work don't join cults yeah there
was actually an episode about the
dangers of following a cult and I I
think like most kids around my age found
out what a cult was by watching this
episode hey it's better than finding out
other ways he had more cheese wedges and
he could count but he's far richer in
spirit now that he's giving up all his
wealth to be fist it's actually pretty
clever social satire a group of mice
mistake a Cola commercial you know the
ones that always say you don't belong
unless you buy our product and they turn
it into a literal interpretation huh we
would all lost once they Paul we found
the cola code and I'll be damned if I
can't remember one algebraic equation
from all my days of school but yet years
later I still remember every fucking
word of the coca-cola saw
[Music]
it was cute it was clever it had
characters we could never forget it was
a whole lot of life after Chippendale
wrapped up
we've been moved on to a show with a
familiar character who's a bumbling
pilot with his gigantic plane and the
timeless environment that he inhabited
I'm talking of course about the jungle
book tales Ben is arguably one of the
stranger setups not because of the plot
itself about a delivery pilot who
battles air pirates along with his
psychic kit but why the jungle book
characters it's like having the cast of
Bambi in a film noir it doesn't add up
well maybe part of it is that
surprisingly jungle book after inflation
was the fourth highest-grossing Disney
film at that time so I guess they figure
it it made sense to give on their own
show but even then there's only three
characters that ever made it in blue
Louie and Shere Khan where are the other
guys would it be great to seek I'm there
or ha but then again to their credit
maybe that's all they needed as those of
the characters stood on their own quite
nicely it was sort of the everyday kid
you wanted to be especially when he was
flying around on that glider thing he's
kind of like an adorable Green Goblin I
mean more adorable they already is Baloo
told me never to talk to strangers and
I've never met anybody stranger than you
jeweled kid there was Rebecca who ran
the business a lot of people didn't like
but honestly I think she's a perfect
comic foil just look at all these
reactions when Baloo tries to disguise
his friend as a scientist gutentag bo
joy are you doing what are you doing in
that getup ah you have me confused with
someone entirely not myself I'm doctor
spend Philippe gesundheit BVD you mean
PhD oh that bad too
she even plays along and finding ways to
teach Baloo a lesson for trying such a
lazy scheme
just checking to see if you've landed on
Mars yet
yeah and it's bad time here
what did bother me though was her kid
Molly was sort of like a Webby 2.0 she
was just as annoying just as cute silly
pandering and just as inconsistent in
her appearances sometimes Rebecca needed
a sitter for her all their time she was
in order to be seen where the hell she'd
go in the middle of those episodes I
think she was just an unused gummy bear
that they decided to fit in somewhere
[Music]
needless to say any episode centered
around her definitely needed more air
missiles falling in their direction just
wait'll you tune in next week
[Music]
and then of course there's Don karnage
the mechanized knows all that they
feared by repeat stood oh no no ohh
how does one describe Don karnage
imagine if Ricky Ricardo got fed up with
his wife took his Caribbean band and
just started robbing the shit out of
people
you got pretty much as hilarious of
villain as you can conceive how is it
this guy never got a spin-off show he's
fuckin hilarious and I know what you're
thinking yeah he's a pirate he's a bad
guy so that would be good for kids but
hey Pirates were kind of the first forms
of democracy I mean come on all this
pirates have different accents and hell
I think Don karnage has like eight
different accents in his one voice
[Music]
insecurity is teaching kids about being
together with all sorts of different
races even if you are a million
different races in one somehow it can
work
Disney make it happen Oh Little Britches
sadism so for such a strange combination
of characters and timelines tails Ben
had a great feel
charming characters I had enough air
battles to keep any kid happy but sadly
this would spell the end for Disney's
phenomenal run what you didn't like
Darkwing Duck how dare you win the kid I
don't like that going doc do I have to
get out my people who don't like duck
men duck gun I was talking about the
fact that they never did a good Disney
Afternoon and Capcom game again I mean
come on Baloo's head is the size of the
plane that's just dumb
well then why don't you just explain
what darkwing duck is for those who
don't know which is obviously not me
[Music]
he is the terror that flaps in the night
he is the now that verbs your other noun
he is dark yeah a funny superhero was
really nothing new but part of what made
darkwing duck so great was that majority
of the time he wasn't doing it because
he thought it was right he did for the
exact opposite reason any superhero
should he did it for fame and fortune
really think about that we've seen a ton
of egotistical funny villains but Disney
has never really had a hero that was
full of himself constantly looking for
attention and even sometimes endangering
the mission so that he can get all the
glory let me guess you come to hell
everyone jumping on my crime-fighting
bandwagon yeah we've had a side
character here and there but this is a
main character a main Disney character
the focus of good morals and yet he
constantly comes across as 100%
egotistical in every single scene he's
in he even provides its own narrations
out loud like a little kid he had
watched the city clean of crime like but
maybe that's why we indulged him so much
it wasn't as much a nasty need for
attention as much as like a little kid
looking for attention trying to be the
center by being the hero
and technically following his dreams you
know that is misguided it's still
well-meaning I should have worked with
the team no perfect some team they
turned out to be I guess I'll have to go
save them he of course had side
characters like an excitable tomboy
daughter named Gosselin the return of
ducktales character launch pad fake
wrestling's fake and a slew of pretty
inventive baddies including a shocking
Rodat named megavolt a crime boss named
steel beak why we thought was foul mouth
thrown up maybe he lost his beak by
swearing to Colombian drug lords or
something and his arch-nemesis negaduck
that's the end
after we dad little-known fact Jim
Cummings voices naked uh kills five
puppies every single time he speaks I
get the loot also in my opinion Darkwing
was the first time we had a legitimately
unique kid character in the Disney
Afternoon not that the past ones were
bad but they were just kind of the
typical nice kind of troublemaking
generic kids there is only one Gosselin
she is wild she is funny she is always
part of the action you'll get your own
[Music]
and she complements Darkwing perfectly
seeing how he has the dreams that he go
have a little kid and she literally is a
little kid so there's a legitimate
connection as well as an art for him to
learn how to be a parent whatever
there's an evildoer evildoing the show
was also great as satirizing everything
superhero oriented while still being its
own thing how many of those analogies
did he make up to describe how fearsome
he is I am the middle key from the
sardine can of justice I am the hair in
the lens of your projector
I am the parking meter that expires
while you shop I am the tube of cadmium
yellow that's impossible to open
Darkwing Duck was one of the Disney
afternoons best shows ever let's see
[Music]
before sadly its inevitable decline
decline
what do you mean decline well like any
ongoing series that we love what goes up
must ventually come down Bob we'll worry
about them the second half for now what
do you say we all watch commercials
while eating some Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle food snacks you you held on to
those since the 90s
oh no the current oh well pack with that
I'm gonna reconnect with my little pony
oh you held on to that since childhood
no it's current well I'm gonna reconnect
with my nostalgia by playing with my
transformer did you get that of your
attic no it's perfect
well let's do something that's not
current by watching children's cartoons
while talking over them nothing's
changed
[Applause]
all right so you're saying that the
Disney Afternoon like downhill after
darkwing duck does that mean you hate
goof troop no oh good
ish guru by no means is a bad show it's
heard around goofy and his son Max
living in suburbia next to Pete and his
family PJ peg and pistol it still had a
lot of funny characters humorous
situations and a big deal of heart but
this is back when Disney was trying to
be
just look at this music video that
premieres with the first episode and
tell me you're not getting that vibe
[Music]
just a little bit oh yeah all the kids
are gonna be doing the goofy this week I
get the feeling the Mad Hatter's gonna
steal a mover too from this this is
total jig eNOS
[Music]
aside from maybe kid wearing a backwards
hat which even then you could argue keep
the Hat on better ways flying the past
Disney shows had a timeless feel just
trying to tell good stories with good
characters and aside from this Wonder
Bread there's still this very strong
indication that goof troop was the first
time the Disney Afternoon was trying to
be hip and with-it give up the shades
heaven ride a skateboard have it be
totally embarrassed by his dorky dad but
because the nineties are so
anti-authority bubble tape is not part
of a well-balanced diet because of that
Max is not exactly the most interesting
character he's sort of just some 90
stereotyped kid we assign most shows and
movies around that he's cool but he can
stir up
he has attitude but possesses a good
heart he has a rocket hair style baggy
clothes and he's into anything that's
true I feel like I'm losing the cherry
on my sundae but to the show's credit
he's not annoying per se there's just
not much to it for me the real focus of
the show was on Pete's family I wish the
show was just based on these guys this
is where the real comedy gold was sick
you have an overbearing father a
completely neurotic son a half time but
half threatening mother and a psychotic
little daughter seriously who needs a
kit pistol now go out there and uphold
the family IQ I loved these guys I
wanted more of them in fact why could
they have the title of the show call it
Pete Pete
okay pal needs work but you get the idea
I think because shows like home
improvement and Family Matters were just
as popular with kids as they were with
adults there's this big push to throw
away the wild imagine of worlds and
stick to the all too comforting all too
boring realms of suburbia and what fun
is that in an animated show at least for
kids I mean what kind of
ventures ever happened in suburbia
except that but again as everyday
cartoon shows go
troupe still got a few labs and had
enough enjoyable characters to keep it
afloat bonkers on the other hand a one
more City based than suburban base
bunkers problem wasn't that the location
was horrendously passe it's that the
idea was horrendously passe now tell me
this set of South familiar a tune of a
cop Roger Rabbit yeah you don't really
need an explanation after that do you as
soon as you throw in a tune and a cop
that's the first thing you're gonna
think of but hey maybe it'll be cool
like remember how great it was to see
all those famous cartoon characters
walking around with Disney's endless
library of unforgettables surely we'll
see some of them here right well I saw
the Mad Hatter in the opening I saw
Dumbo for a second there watching
Darkwing Duck on TV that doesn't count
and literally there's a whole episode
where Mickey Mouse is kept in a carrier
cage the whole time and you never see
him and I mean never see him what is the
purpose of having Mickey Mouse on your
show if you're never going to show him
did Mickey just want more money we not
come out of his trailer unless they
doubled his salary and surely bonkers
the main character of the show would in
no way be so annoying you'd rather smash
a hammer against your ears to experience
a more pleasant sound electrocute me
fight me to a crisp the police
[Music]
yes bonkers was Calicut mixed between
the Garbage Pail Kids and snarf yet
somehow they thought audiences would
want to return to this even the side
characters one of them being a
stick-in-the-mud cop who has no sense of
humor I sure AM I know I know it's a
little confusing because at least a
Roger Rabbit it was live-action and
animation here it's all animation so the
wonder that doesn't really stick out I
mean yeah you get the idea that all the
drawn people are supposed to be real
people but let's say they come across a
cartoon of Aladdin you wouldn't know
which one was supposed to be the two and
then which one was supposed to be real
would Jeff which is why I'm sorry to say
kids there will never be an Aladdin and
bonkers crossover even Animaniacs who
share the same time slot took a pretty
mean dig at it every once in a while and
no wonder you like that bonkers show the
junk strutting out your brain man it
wasn't funny it wasn't creative pretty
much everything about had already been
done before it was a show that was in
desperate need of an eraser
[Applause]
[Music]
headless Disney would never do anything
different anything original or anything
groundbreaking ever ok twine gargoyles
like ducktales I've talked about many
times before so I won't love too much
but looking back at the other shows
Disney was turning out and how safe they
were playing it for a while if he'd be
more and more just what do you meet risk
gargoyles kind of was for them it was
their first straight on serious show and
their TV animation which hadn't really
done anything quite as heavy or dramatic
stepped up its active really gave
something that Disney shows weren't
doing at that time
dan debatably haven't really done since
it didn't need a hip-hop theme song or
popular catchphrases to be badass it
just had to be badass to be badass and I
came from it's strong heroes it's
complex villains and it's dark Grimm's
style also half the cast of every Star
Trek series ever made helps - it was a
fantastic show and we loved every single
minute on why because never once did it
ever rely on any sort of cheap disney
gimmicks we had a landed for that
[Music]
I'll try not to step on too many toes as
I know a lot of people like this show
and an old fairness it's not a bad idea
for a show I'll let it offered a lot of
great scenarios that could be taken
right out of Arabian Nights and I'll
also give kudos that I actually do
remember a lot of the characters they
created I remember a be small Mirage
sadirah chaos that other Aladdin with
the girlie lips these were all cool
creations that left memorable
impressions strangely enough the
problems with the show were more
centered on the main characters even
though their popularity had already made
a ton of money in the past but let's be
honest what made a lot of the original
movies so great was its imagination and
its humor here we have the imagination
but instead of Robin Williams
improvisation as we get oh did you risk
upon a bet Homer Simpson bombing at
stand-up and yes that is Homer's Boys
dan Castellaneta clearly giving it his
all but the scripts he's handed gives
him very little to work with aladdin and
Jasmine are strong enough to hold a
movie but here they're so bland you can
replace them with an empty shell and
Michael Eisner saying that's you you're
doing that the monkey still sounds like
a choking Donald Duck and by Jesus on
Broadway there is way too much Gilbert
Godfrey on this show why do people keep
casting me as irritatingly annoying
Birds the animation too is a little
strange as half of its trying to be
realistic like gargoyles but then the
other half is trying to be cartoony like
bonkers so you end up with big
expressionless eyes on what looks like
stretchy erasers look at these they look
more like flesh colored play-doh than
they do Aladdin I'm not even sure it
makes sense in the movie they say they
have to marry in three days but they're
still not hitched in the show and if
Aladdin is allowed to live in the palace
now how come he's still wearing the
clothes he wore as a thief does Jazmin
just really like the Middle Eastern male
stripper look I guess it's a show based
on a movie go Z
could have been a lot worse but trying
to capture that Disney movie feel seems
to work better when you can expand with
your main characters not be restricted
by them natural
[Music]
but not all Disney shows based on Disney
movies have to be bad they just had to
have annoying theme
there's not really too much to say about
Timon and Pumba either not because it's
bad on the contrary it delivers exactly
what it promises its Timon and Pumbaa in
high jinks goofy situations and silly
scenarios that's about all you needed
and that's about all delivered the
animation was fine the timing was decent
and it never felt like it had to be too
restricted to their environment they
could still do fun cartoony things that
fought in cartoons usually do
it's totally serviceable hell I dare
even say they're a lot funnier here and
then they are in the movie but sadly for
every Timon and Pumbaa there's a Chinook
ensue
snookums and what yeah I don't remember
that well that's because we're starting
to get into the half seasons you see as
the Disney Afternoon started to lose its
audience it took one of their timeslot
and we constantly alternate in between
shows so Tuesday at 4:00 might be
bonkers but Wednesday at 4:00 could be
gargoyles and Friday at 4:00 could be
Legend of Zelda
I mean tokens a meet this was part of
their attempt to just throw stuff at the
wall to see what sticks and it's
Newcomb's and meet stay if by static you
mean I like to impale them on something
very sharp just look at this intro and
tell me for mine too of anything
anything familiar at all if you thought
bonkers ripping off Roger Rabbit was bad
this was just uncomfortable from the
surreal animation to the paint drop
backgrounds to the semi realistic stills
to the fact that it's a cat and a
goddamn dog it was pretty fucking
painful it's like watching a kid dance
well and then another less talented kid
says he can do the same thing and then
ends up copying a terrible cartoon show
and let me tell you if you thought
bonkers was annoying take a listen to
this I protect the house from intruders
oh yeah well I think stupid wise okay no
I think he's just reacting to the sound
of their voices the animation is still
Disney too even though they're trying to
be different it's still clearly out of
their comfort zone it still looks a
little too polished and safe to be
anything like the all-out insanity that
Ren and Stimpy gave us the creator of
the show went on to do eat the cat which
also had a Ren Stimpy feel but was still
unique enough to be called its own show
this is the equivalent of a video game
reviewer seeing another video game
reviewer and trying to do exactly the
same thing but not even coming close to
villian your own punchline here but as
bad as this is it still doesn't compare
to the final two shows desperate enough
to cash in on what Disney considered at
the time major Edie
do this what show is that
you know how goofed Ruth kind of
exploited speaking the language of our
personality deprived youth well quack
pack is the fucking parade point just
look at this intro stripped that's not
current in hip oh yeah now this is
corroded hip we do and movie oh I mean
this will teach that unhip adult not to
be 15 years younger
take that not us
even the song sounds ridiculous and I've
been clothing by Disney standards what
the hell does that mean who wakes up and
says I feel like whacking today did I
miss that thing did I miss that thing
and there's your first problem how do
you make anyone called Huey Dewey and
Louie cool well I think the thought
process is just to take the most popular
of the three home improvement boys and
just make three employees no I'm not
even kidding
these kids have no personalities outside
of Jonathan Taylor Thomas quotes and
nineties poses oh don't know what
nineties poses are I'll give you a run
through the I don't care pranksters the
I don't care belly layers the I don't
care arms folded and/or hands in pockets
the I don't care shrunk followed by the
I don't care resting hands behind my
head and the constant constant
I don't care leaning against anything I
can lean against but hey they don't need
personalities because they use radical
abbreviations like Uncle Dean we've got
a room to clean we'll if it worked in
the Brady Bunch in Sunny Delight
commercials surely our youth must be
saying it nowadays a disgusting sight
granted it's not like they've never used
abbreviations before and what's
something about those initials just has
a good ring to it the stories mostly
seemed to center around weird
experiments superheroes top-secret
missions pretty much anything they
wanted which would be great if you want
to see any of these characters go
through any of those you don't because
it's fucking Huey Dewey and Louie yeah
without the incredibly rich duck or the
incredibly funny Huey Dewey Louie you're
not interesting characters I love to see
darkwing duck go through all of this I
love to see the Rescue Rangers go
through all of this but those are great
characters I wanted to follow these are
just the Jonas Brothers if even less
personality was required from them so
many comic books
little time guys everything maybe we
should quit reading all these comics and
do something someone's been reading
self-help books again pitiful so there's
no other way to put it people this show
is pretty bad
so after their attempt at making
has-been ducks look cool they tried
something different Malcolm that would
indicate that Disney would not be five
years behind what's popular and in the
late 90s they were all about that enter
the mighty doctor
[Music]
I guess because they knew ducks weren't
gonna be the big trend for a while yeah
everyone's gonna be saying ducks Rock
this year this will be much better than
fish rule or logs are totally radical
tubular so we were given the show based
on a movie 5 years old that had nothing
to do with the movie that was 5 years
old
in fact the connection is so vague that
you kind of wonder how the hell they got
this set up it's actually kind of
intriguing hey I'm an inspiring show
creator and I wanted to make a series
based on the Mighty Ducks the kids with
the hockey team yeah I love it
except uh can we make the kids ducks
well it is a kids show so I guess that's
okay okay can we make them teenagers
because little kids won't be teenagers
it's really big right now I suppose it
can we have some fighting aliens in
another dimension where there's nothing
but ducks and hockey is more of a side
thing that has nothing to do with my
idea but has everything to do with my
idea I'm glad we found a compromise hog
to me and yes that is the story they
come from a dimension where everything
is obsessed with hockey heck even the
asteroids look like hockey pucks because
they didn't want to seem uncool and
dimensions are crossed between our world
and a world populated by ducks
oh sweet Jesus is Howard the Duck all
over again quick hide your squeaking two
provinces once again the main characters
came down to the typical team
stereotypes except this time it truly
was dated including the stern leader the
muscle the goof off and you dunderheads
can't steal a simple piece of aluminum
oxide okay the only advantage it has is
that Tim Curry is the villain and the
only bigger advantage than that was that
Tony J the voice of Frollo was his
second hand man that
piece of aluminum oxide has a very
complicated alarm system okay
I am totally Pro Tim Curry and Tony J
sharing any scene under any
circumstances the battle is on to see
which one of our voices can get women to
orgasm France that easy
my voice is ten times deep but my voice
is so much sexier I could make the food
books are juicy I can wear women's
clothing and still be hot we could even
sound sex you saved the most dogs sexy
together
stocks rock god that really does suck
the cool out of everything
my role in Congo is sounding good about
now like I said it was stupid it was
painful
it was beyond for us and it was the
final nail in the coffin that killed the
Disney Afternoon
[Music]
well that's kind of a shame that
everything ended up going down a hill
like that well in the end it really
doesn't matter because that's not what
people remember the Disney Afternoon for
it's remember for all the creativity all
the comedy all the colorful characters
all the unforgettable worlds everything
has to have an end and at least they
went out on such a stupidly bad no it
couldn't be forgot the people who
remember the Disney Afternoon remember
it as something to look forward to after
school the shows that were there to
greet them after such a long day and
that was its secret
it wasn't badass threatening or consumed
by what was popular it was welcoming
friendly and smart it realized early on
that the way to become popular is not
following the rules that everybody else
is doing but redefining the rules heck
playing a whole different game and with
all the effort put into these awesome
shows they're still gonna stick with us
even years after they've been pulled off
the air bring at you again
well Disney Afternoon is over now what
do we do son
you do your homework right now your butt
is what I'm gonna kick if you don't get
to your algebra you gotta do your
homework you too now
mom that's right you better get your
butt busy right now you got my mom I
wanted to be authentic wait did you get
mine too
no she was all the way out in California
and I was too lazy to get ticket so I
got your grandma your name you'll be get
your attitudes and books rather be
getting this mist into your eyes well I
got a grandma go make me back my boot
upside to downside you backside Wow
she's like the white black grama we all
have looked Rock I'm the Nostalgia
Critic and playtime's over
go do your homework while listening to
music because of course it helps you
study so much better
[Music]
oh grandma
[Applause]
[Music]
you
don't rock